this is another one of the dr
sadler's stories videos that viewers and
subscribers
have been asking for you know stories
about my my personal life
there's a lot of memories that these
allow me to bring up and that's kind of
fun
so what i'm going to talk about this
time is not particularly
fun but it was life-changing in some
significant ways
and it was a major injury that i had
about a little bit more than seven years
ago
and it happened out at montauk which is
on long island it's about as far
out as you can get on long island and we
would go out there
uh before the the big tourist season
started
and spend you know some some time out
there uh my wife who did all the booking
for this and who
had been going to montauk for quite a
long time and then my my
two kids and you know we'd spend a lot
of time on the beach
and eating seafood and taking it easy
and having a good time and
you know you've got to be a little bit
careful because it is
the ocean so i wasn't being
careful one day but i didn't think this
would actually happen to me in this way
so it was towards the end of
one of our our trips out there
and we've been staying there for for a
while and
it was kind of a you know the waves were
a bit rougher that day
and so i was you know going out to to
wash off we'd done all sorts of things
like buried ourselves in the sand
and i was going out into the waves and
they were they're pretty high
at that time and what i remember
was um turning because my daughter was
it was very windy and she was she was
yelling something and so i was looking
up towards her
and then i got hit by a wave and it was
it was a big one and it
knocked me under and i
heard something like in sort of like i
could
hear it in my head but i think it was a
reverberation of what was going on
i kind of pop and suddenly there was
all this this pain uh just kind of
flooding me from my leg
and i didn't know what was going on so
you know by that time i was under water
unfortunately you know the wave is is
moving you towards the shore so as the
wave receded i
i you know like grabbed onto the sand
and started
uh moving moving upwards and i was in a
lot of pain already like probably the
worst pain
of my life and i've done a lot of
painful things you know including like
branding
a hand and getting shocked by
by electrical currents and you know
slicing my thumb open
all sorts of stupid things getting hit
in the head with a rock
this was probably the worst pain i'd
ever felt
and i you know i knew i had to get
myself
out of the surf so so i did that and i
got up there and i immediately like
tried to get
up and as it turned out i had actually
damaged beyond repair two
ligaments actually more than two
ligaments i'll talk about that in a
moment but
two main ligaments in my left knee
so you know the ligaments are the things
that kind of hold your knee together and
stabilize it
there's four main ones in your knee and
so you know
damaging two of them effectively
breaking them
uh that that's a big problem so i tried
to to stand up
and immediately you know my
my left knee just like it was like
looking at a chicken leg it was like
flopping around
that was scary and by that time my
my daughter was coming down to the beach
and you know
what my wife could tell there was
something wrong and eventually
you know everybody's around me and we
got me able to to sit up
um and then uh it got away from from the
actual
beach and moved up a bit and then it was
like a whole
production because how do you get
somebody
who's you know a big guy out of
a place like that they ended up having
to put me in the back of a
pickup truck and then it was a ride
to the local hospital where they started
doing you know x-rays and tests and
things like that
and the whole time you know man my leg
was just
killing me and i think they probably
must have given me some
painkillers at the time but i don't
really remember um and it was
supposed to be stabilized and so you
know my
wife took the kids and
they were pretty young so seeing
their dad go down like that is pretty
scary for them as well so she took them
to get some
some tacos and and you know
i i had to be there in the hospital
because you know
where else are you gonna go and so you
know eventually they uh they discharged
me
and they i i don't remember exactly
what they had at that time but they had
something to immobilize
my my leg uh it might have been some one
of those plastic almost like cast
like things and then it was you know
we had to move i didn't do any moving
obviously i was
incapacitated but my my wife and kids
had to move
our stuff out of the uh
the second floor cabin that we were
staying in
into a first floor cabin the people who
um
you know we were staying with they they
had a beach motel
they uh you know accommodated us which
was great and
all i remember is watching some tv
talking with you know my wife and kids
being in a good bit of pain
and you know trying to find positions
that i could get
comfortable in so i could get some some
sleep
and then after that you know it was um
that was basically our last day or so
at montauk and then we had to drive back
back home
to the hudson valley and if you don't
know the geography of new york
so the hudson valley is north of new
york city
right and long island is east of
new york city so you've got to go and
montauk is at the very end
of long island so you got to go all the
way across long island and then back up
through
new york city and then up into the
hudson valley
and we were at the time living in what's
called the carriage house
apartment which is essentially an
apartment above a garage
so all these stairs um
i think they gave they gave me some
crutches as well which was nice
um and so you know i've got this this
thing on immobilizing my
my leg and then some crutches and we had
to get you know
up up the stairs and then once i was in
there
you know for at least a couple days i
wasn't going any
much of anywhere um i remember
vaguely that like taking a shower was
kind of dicey and also painful
because anything that i would do
involving that knee
made made things hurt you know and and
there wasn't stuff
there to completely stabilize it when
you're like say taking a shower or
something like that
and so i was i was pretty laid up and
you know it was uh definitely not an
ideal time for that to happen
right um there was uh various things
going on
uh the kids were there and you know um i
don't even remember
quite frankly what we did over the the
next couple days
but what i do remember is over the rest
of the summer as i
you know was able to start moving around
um there were two things basically one
was
a whole set of miscommunications with my
my doctor and um so the first thing i
had to do is actually figure out how
much damage there was
so i went to a place that had you know
mris and they they put me in there
and i didn't like that you get a little
claustrophobic especially if you're a
big person
getting into one of those those machines
but you know sit still and and then they
gave me the bad news
two ligaments uh you know completely
damaged
no no weight you know it wasn't you
don't get partial tears
when you're in your 40s is what they
told me
so you know they were completely torn
and then my my
doctor at the time told me
so you know you can have these replaced
with ligaments from cadavers
but you need to get into shape before
you do that later on he said oh no no
you misunderstood what i
what i said but i think he was probably
quite
unclear he he gave me the impression
that i needed to
like you know rehab it and lose a lot of
weight and stuff like that before we
would do
anything like that and then the next
year when he saw me he's like well how
come you didn't get that fixed and i
said because you
you told me i had to do these other
things first and that didn't happen
so you know there's there's all of that
and i never i never did
end up getting it replaced the the two
ligaments the acl and the mcl
i also tore some of the smaller
ligaments in the kneecap itself
as our doctor here who's a sports
medicine guy
was able to figure out looking at it and
you know
the the remedy for this if you don't get
the ligaments replaced
is you just strengthen the um the
muscles and and everything else around
it as best as you can
and try to avoid taking any sharp curves
you know so
running is out of the picture things
that i really enjoyed in the past
like say racquetball you know i used to
play that back at fsu and enjoyed that
quite a bit
you know and i thought about getting
back into it down the line but that's
not that's not feasible you know
if i wanted to do um you know things
like like soccer
i'd have to avoid sharp movements
because it can
put the things out of out of
whatever you know out of alignment and
that's painful as hell when that happens
so you know what i did is i strengthened
everything and and the last couple times
that i've been to the doctor he said
well you maxed out on that you can't get
it any stronger than it already is
so you know you've basically reached the
peak of what you've got available for
that knee
and it does give me some trouble you
know every once in a while it'll be a
little loosey-goosey if i take
long walks it can hurt depending on the
weather
my other knee compensating for it has
probably taken a lot of abuse
over the years as well the other thing
that happened was i was on
crutches and with a brace
on on that knee usually worn like you
know if i was wearing shorts obviously i
could just wear the brace
and if i was wearing pants the brace was
kind of cumbersome
so i'd wear it over my my pants you know
like jeans or
corduroys or dress pants or stuff like
that
and for most of the summer
i was on crutches um
for quite a while with two crutches
right and then like i'd go to the
grocery store and
and uh you know i take the cart and then
i could like have the
crutches in the cart and use the cart
almost like people use a walker and that
was okay you know but then i had to be
careful if i got
you know getting something make sure i
use a and then over time as things got
stronger
you know i i didn't need it so much i
know that i was still
by the end of the summer by
august i was still using both crutches
because i
actually went to an academic conference
in grand rapids for the international
society for
mcintyre and inquiry and i flew
from jfk to chicago and then took a car
from chicago
to grand rapids and then drove back
again
and did that and the driving wasn't bad
because you know if it had been like my
my right leg that might have been a bit
of a pain but
left leg it's not not that big of a deal
but then you know
going from place to place um it was at
grand valley state
university for part of it so i had a lot
of walking to do
and i just remember it was like hot as
hell because it was august you know in
the midwest
and i've got you know i'm dressed in my
academic like gear you know
with you know dress pants and
a shirt and tie and a jacket and you
know my dossier and my
my crutches and gambling around from
place to place to place and then you
know getting back to the conference
hotel um and everyone was a good sport
about it
you know and so that was it was kind of
interesting
and then it was the start of the school
year and i was teaching
at marist college in poughkeepsie new
york and i remember that semester
most of that semester i had the brace
and i think i was
for at the very beginning i was using
two crutches
and then you get down to one crutch and
then after a while
you're supposed to like you know go
without crutches at all but still the
brace
and i think that's where i was by by
december
so for some of those classes that i was
i was teaching i was um you know kind of
a little bit handicapped and you know
when when something like this happens
especially if you're
generally pretty healthy otherwise it
really drives home to you how quickly
things can go topsy-turvy and how
how lasting damage can happen to your
body i mean when you're in your
teens and twenties it's not like bad
things can't happen but if you tear in
you know a ligament it might be only a
partial tear
and then they'll probably fix it for you
or
you know uh but when you're in your 40s
things are you know you're in middle age
and you really got to start being
more prudent and careful with your body
and this is one of those things that
you know who could have predicted it i
mean it's i suppose somebody with a
uh you know god-like understanding of
wave mechanics perhaps
on the human body but it was one of
those fluke
things that just just happens to you
and you know since then i i have been
active i walk quite a bit
i you know exercise i do i do leg work
when i go into the gym
i've got to wear some some braces for my
my knees just to make sure that you know
i don't screw
anything up but you know i'm able to
live a pretty
active life but there's there's quite a
few things that i just can't do
or if i do i i pay a toll for it you
know like i have
run a few times since then but that
really takes it out of you when you're
doing that and it's always kind of kind
of taking a chance
you never know if something could go go
badly with that
but it was um yeah it was a that was
really like the first thing that i
i did where i really screwed something
up on my body
in a permanent way like i said you know
i almost cut my
thumb off when i was a kid i was carving
towards myself like a dummy
with a box cutter and it slipped and i
you know cut cut
half halfway into my thumb
you know i've had some falls and you
know certainly like you know some
accidents with skateboards and bikes and
even you know car crashes
but nothing that ever like you know
changed the the condition for me for
good
and hopefully this will be the last one
until the ultimate
you know change for the body which is uh
dying
maybe i could keep myself from getting
any any other
injuries of that sort be before that
but if not you know i know how to roll
with it and
and it really does change your
perspective you know you take so many
things for granted
and then you're hobbling around you
can't go very far it's painful to move
you know you start to think about how
accessibility figures into things and
you know why why isn't there an easy
walk
over here why does everything have to be
upstairs
you know where you can't use the
elevator and have to go up several
flights of stairs
those sorts of things really bring it
home to
you so yeah so that's the story of uh
tearing these two ligaments in my left
knee hopefully that'll be all the
ligaments i
tear going forward you know i found a
good way to
live with without them live with the
the limited capacity that it leaves
my left knee i'm pretty lucky pretty
fortunate that it's not worse than it is
i i think you can say and so that's
that's the story
you